this will show her not to mess with us
again or big and we're bad Khloe
Kardashian is one of the baddest in the
game but let's be real the girl's been
through a lot
hashtag et is running down khlo money's
most shocking moments first up her
quickie wedding I want to get married
right now
Beauty married the door right now 2009
after just 30 days of dating Chloe tied
the knot with NBA star Lamar Odom you
are husband and wife
four years later in 2013 the couple
decided to go their separate ways but
Chloe's stunned us again withdrawing her
pending divorce papers in order to make
medical decisions for Lamar after he
suffered in overdose at the end of the
day I want Lamar to be happy and if I
could keep him safe and that's a match
made in heaven
ET sat down with Lamar in May 20 19 he
was still full of gratitude for what
Khloe did thank you for being there for
me when I can't walk or talk my piece of
paper just says that we're not together
that love will never go away Khloe
started a new chapter in her life with a
jaw-dropping new look and a new show
called what else
revenge body we're gonna give you your
life back it's mind body and soul I
never thought of my body as revenge I
just did something for myself I think
it's important to show people you can
turn your life around
you can go through hell and high water
but you can still come out and have a
beautiful positive happy life Koko moved
on and after a string of high-profile
romances she found love with another NBA
star Tristan Thompson I am really really
excited about my future just me
interesting like we're doing so well
only one small problem
Tristan had a baby on the way with
another woman a show crazy Khloe spoke
out about the controversy on Instagram
writing in a lengthy statement that
Tristan and his closest pals swore to
her that things between him and his ex
were over quote I pray my truth is in
fact that a year and a half after
Tristan welcomed a baby boy with his ex
he welcomed a baby girl with khloe named
true it's complete bliss and just the
love that you got you that you also get
to give and receive it's just it's
beautiful but the days leading up to
trues birth were dramatic to say the
least
Tristan was accused of cheating on Khloe
after videos of him getting intimate
with other women hit the web
I want Tristan here with me I want to
experience this magical moment and I
mature enough to
you know put my my personal feelings
aside
he obviously dumped major but I'm not
sure how I feel about anything right now
fast forward to 2019 Tristan is accused
of cheating on Chloe yet again this time
with kylie jenner's BFF Jordan woods on
the way out he did kiss me it was like a
kiss on the lips but no tongue case no
making out god nothing I'm just like
what were you thinking I knew who he was
I never in a million years thought
that's who she was it just sucks it has
to be so public everyone has the right
to speak their truth and hopefully
everyone is just you know going forward
Annie T's newest interview with Chloe
she said she's chosen to not relive the
drama as it plays out on Keeping Up with
the Kardashians it's just I think a
little too toxic for me to keep reliving
stuff like that so I stay off social I
don't I didn't watch it and it's just a
part of our job that we kind of have to
do I don't think there needs to be
negativity on anywhere I think it's just
a story that's being told but anybody
picking aside or you know condemning any
human I think this is a part of life
life has their own divorce and scandal
Chloe's way but clearly she's one tough
chick I think that's an accomplishment I
felt really good that I found my groove